[Music]
i just got the signal from professor
sean over there to wrap this question up
zachary thanks for your question mike in
columbus mississippi has a question for
us this is mike from columbus
mississippi i'm kind of new back into
the dating market
and i was just wondering what your
advice was for maybe people that are i
don't know maybe even a little insecure
in the bedroom how
to approach that i mean if you have some
concerns is that something you should
address like
right early on when meeting someone
maybe on the first date just so you're
up front or do you tell them you know or
do you wait a little while i guess when
i'm asking
i want to know what more i would like to
know more like what those concerns
actually are but i guess we can kind of
i would never uh uh announce the
insecurity because in it just taking a
black light to it unless it's something
that you have that is um um uh uh
something that you've been struggling
with your whole life that's maybe like
like for example like um um erectile
dysfunction or something like that
that's very obvious so there can be a
conversation about that right
um would you wouldn't have that on the i
wouldn't lead with that
yeah i mean yeah and by the way let's
talk i mean if you talk about ed real
quick that is a marketing term that was
invented by an ad agent to make money on
pills yes yeah to sell you prescriptions
essentially right and so we pathologize
almost everything yeah right
as therapists you all recognize how much
we pathologize our insecurities and
those insecurities have been created by
the people who want to sell us the cure
and they can only cure us if we have an
insecurity around that thing right so
maybe it's normalizing the insecurity
maybe what he's insecure about he
doesn't have to be insecure about but
because um you know commercials and
advertising and and i don't know uh
his blueprint of what he's tracing of
what it looks it should look like in the
bedroom so for example pornography and
and locker rooms if he's comparing his
love experience to um a giant should
then
maybe uh his expectations are very high
yeah i mean i think going on what you
were saying josh it's like when you look
at things like whether it's ed whether
it's like we were talking about
depression all these things it's like
these quote unquote symptoms usually are
there to either teach us something
they're actually there for us to look at
and examine more closely they might be
looked at even as an opportunity like
there might even be something that
that's giving us like providing us so um
i mean we're assuming it's ed we don't
actually know that's what he's talking
about well actually i heard a longer
version i don't know what the hell
podcast sean did to edit this out okay
but there was totally a question about
having a micro penis in here oh science
and nicodemus isn't here i'd ask him
about it
damn wow
i'm kidding i'm just intimidated by the
size of his palace
the truth comes out
he has a baby arm
i've known him for 30 years yeah and uh
it's uh it's intimidating uh we've lived
together and my god i run out of the
room terrified crying sometimes hey but
i'd like to decide that's i think it's a
real thing
it totally is yeah and but also what
happens and not to make a pun out of
this but we blow it out of proportion we
make things bigger than what they
actually are
[Laughter]
killing her over here alabama i love you
and and so
but the reason these things become a
problem when they aren't generally a
problem is because we sign
we assign so much weight to some narrow
individual characteristics yeah about
ourselves and our identity gets wrapped
up in that thing right and as soon as we
do that i am this kind of person i'm an
angry person i'm a sad person i am a
person i'm a small penis person whatever
it is right now all of a sudden that's
who i am these are the guard rails i've
set up for myself it's pretty difficult
to get out of that trap that i've set
yeah i mean i'm totally fair i think
that there is also sometimes you can
take the weight out of things when you
do speak about it right and so this idea
of maybe keeping it close to you it does
actually keep some of the power in the
insecurity rather than almost like an
ownership of it like okay this is one
part of many of who i am as a person to
your point this isn't who i am it's a
piece of who i am right what's the rest
of me what are the other components of
self that i'm bringing to the table in
the dating world um you know how can i
actually do work to um i don't know
bring more to the table in other areas
not to necessarily overcompensate but so
that i can show up and say like i am the
best version of myself this is just one
small part oh god one one part of myself
i got myself
the subconscious uh listen freud would
be
[Laughter]
hey
proud
i it's so i'm a grower
oh
i love how honest we're all getting it
i don't have a baby arm uh
i don't have a microphone baby arm but
also it's something that i have been
insecure about
uh for most of my life until i started
uh dating women who said actually i
don't prefer the stuff that we see in
porn movies because it it hurts um your
size is actually i'm okay the best sex
i've ever had actually i will say i
could dance there you go that's the
dancing that ripples into the bedroom
not the size no i'm just kidding
but i realized growing up
in the 80s where parents my parents were
always at work and you know i was at
like 12 being exposed to images um early
on way too early
and then i mean now with the internet
pornography
there's a brainwashing where we think
that we are less than or or
especially as a man the generalization
but men hanging their worth on either
what they've built or their penis size
you know
um so that i could understand the
insecurity of that going into the
bedroom with that insecurity obviously
which is why viagra is the number one
selling product period of all time yeah
oh is it yeah oh wow
yep it's made the most money pretty much
of any i think any at least pill that's
ever been created
wow well you guys don't do commercials
so they won't be on here
this is the anti-viagra commercial i
think actually
one thing i'll say here is that um
the worst thing you can do to any
relationship is to require that
relationship to be all things
every relationship needs the
wisdom and support of other
relationships and this applies to
sexuality as well
if you've got insecurities
that affect you in the bedroom
you need to be having conversations
outside of the bedroom with someone that
you're not going into the bedroom with
so they can help you process those
insecurities and figure out how you're
going to react and respond to them in a
healthy way and i would take that
pressure off of the person you're going
into the bedroom with to be the end-all
be-all in the sense of playing the role
of solving whatever that is amen that
would be but i i anticipated an
objection to my own thoughts here and i
love to
to ask you that this is so great because
now i can answer questions
object to my own questions and then have
you get me out of it
what if you don't have anybody to talk
to about that kind of stuff especially
when it comes to sexuality especially
where it feels very private yeah who who
do you go to
if you have have an insecurity about
something like that i mean i was going
to see a therapist
uh but you're saying if that's not
available if it's too expensive if
that's not your your thing
yeah because i think friends are good
but friends you know they're loaded in
the sense that their um friends can be
very opinionated too close uh it's too
close they could tell you what to do
they can make it about them you know the
job of a therapist is to keep the space
neutral and process it and that's i
think the most effective way um friends
and family although they love you and
they're not doing it intentionally
sometimes i is the worst place to go
here's what i'll say i agree therapy can
be very expensive it is a huge barrier
to mental health right and again we
could go on a whole tangent about the
way the system is structured in this
country
but the the beauty i have a love hate
relationship with social media the
beauty of social media has actually been
that it has made a lot of things more
accessible to many so social you know
mental wellness mental health even
coaches like there are coaches that
specialize in
sex and sexuality and all of these
things that i am sure you could find and
connect with somebody out there that's
kind of speaking your language that
could give you
tips or ways to talk about things
scripts things like this that could
benefit you in this area of your life
it just takes a little bit of work you
know even finding a good therapist takes
work it's not going to be i meet this
one person automatically the best
therapist ever that's very rare i say
finding a therapist is like dating a lot
of times you got to find that person
that you kind of vibe with you know
but i would say if you don't have the
means to have a therapist
i agree with you friends and family are
not normally the place to go it could be
support groups i think
group work has been very minimal
minimized i think that we're actually
finally coming into understanding
actually group work can be
hugely beneficial because we are social
creatures and we do learn through other
people so finding support groups which
i'm sure exists especially now
everything's online everything is done
via zoom i'm sure you could find groups
out there that you could connect to that
would be my go-to did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
theminimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel
100
advertisement free